[Musica]
avete mai visto delle piante che
reagiscono al contatto
ho iniziato a suonare la batteria sette
anni e dopo poco ho subito
mi sono subito lasciato prendere da
tutto quello che è la registrazione i
suoni e le tecnologie ad esse ad esso
collegate
ho cominciato a fare un po di carriera
come tecnico del suono come batterista e
dopo un po di anni ho cominciato anche a
collaborare con artisti che realizzavano
installazioni
insomma i lavori nei musei
fondamentalmente e allora ho cominciato
a sviluppare una mia idea riguardo
l'arte l'arte credo che faccia parte di
ognuno di noi
credo che sin da bambini
si possa sviluppare una sensibilità
artistica eccomi qua
è quindi ogni persona può avere una
parte di arte di
contaminazione dentro di sé
dopo un po di tempo di queste
collaborazioni con questi artisti ho
cominciato a sviluppare delle mie idee
quindi ho subito cominciato ad aver
bisogno di sviluppare anche dei delle
apparecchiature dei meccanismi e delle
soluzioni per mettere in pratica questa
idea che mi venivano sempre più in mente
ma come sono arrivato fino a qui
soprattutto il primo la prima persona
che voglio citare angelo tripodi che è
stato il mio maestro di batteria ma
anche il mio maestro di vita
lui mi ha insegnato utilizzare le
orecchie in un modo diverso e ampliato
in qualche modo la mia percezione
facendo in modo suo grandissimo
insegnamento di
riuscire a mettere in relazione forte
quello che la mia interiorità con quello
che c'è il lecce fuori da me
un cambiamento forte del mio punto di
vista rispetto alla natura è stato
invece causato da stefano mancuso che è
un famoso il neurobiologo vegetale lui è
riuscito a elaborare delle teorie molto
interessante una delle quali
racconta che le piante essendo molto più
antiche del degli esseri diciamo mobili
come siamo noi
in qualche modo abbiano sviluppo dei
sistemi per levarci e per fare in modo
che loro interesse e cioè la diffusione
della vita riesca riuscisse insomma
diffondersi in tutto il mondo
quindi il frutto buono il relativo sane
che viene diffuso a distanza o i semi
che si attaccano al pelo insomma delle
teorie molto affascinanti che fanno
cambiare sempre il punto di vista sulla
realtà
la terza persona che sa che devo citare
che ha allargato veramente il mio
panorama come dire creativo è stato
matteo inì che è la persona che mi ha
fatto scoprire questo sistema di cui vi
sto per parlare
neanche aiutato a realizzare la prima
installazione quindi gli devo molto
questo sistema
un sistema che diciamo si può far
risalire agli anni 60 con l'invenzione
della macchina della verità
in effetti chiunque con un po di
conoscenze di elettronica può cimentarsi
a realizzarlo perché è un progetto
liberamente disponibile online e che può
essere realizzato con facilità
ma come funziona questo sistema
questo sistema riesce a captare delle
microscopiche variazioni elettrica che
avvengono nella pianta nel momento in
cui il corpo umano
comincia a toccarlo e quindi il corpo
una sua elettricità la piante ne è
un'altra il momento in cui io entro in
contatto
queste due correnti fluttuando si
sincronizzano nel momento in cui questa
votazione avviene
in quel momento il sistema manda un
segnale ai sintetizzatori che sono
quelli che proteggono il suolo qual è il
mio ruolo all'interno di questo sistema
il mio ruolo è quello di programmare
sintetizzatori per riuscire ad ottenere
il suono più adatto e più
efficace rispetto al contesto di
riferimento che noi dobbiamo
che mi viene commissionato nel lavoro
specifico e qui c'è un'immagine del bio
data e come si può collegare le piante
questo sistema mi ha arricchito molto
perché mi ha fatto ulteriormente
cambiare punto di vista sulla natura
quello che vi sarete un soprammobile in
questo caso diventa un bellissimo
sistema che trasforma
[Musica]
veramente questo oggetto in un essere
vivente
le variabili in gioco in questo caso
oltre a mettere in evidenza l'unicità
degli esseri umani all'uscita
dell'unicità delle piante
le variabili in gioco sono tantissime
intanto la piante può avere una
temperatura della terra una temperatura
dell'aria un'umidità uno stato di
vegetativo
quanta acqua gli sia stata danni sia
stata data in più l'essere umano porta
un ulteriore grande serie di variabili
che possono essere la quantità di
elettori litri la quantità di massa
grassa la quantità di acqua che abbiamo
assunto il tipo di pelle perché è il
contatto quello che fa la differenza
il il modo in cui questo tutte queste
variabili
si mettono insieme creano una specie di
sentiero che io posso percorrere insieme
ai visitatori che partecipano a queste
installazioni per cercare di scoprire
quali sono queste queste emozioni che
vengono fuori
il bello di questa di questi momenti è
che le persone si abbandonano
completamente a quello che le ricerche
di un tocco che può cambiare in base il
suono cambia in base a come io mi decido
di rapportarmi se decido di essere più
presente dove può cambiare oppure no
ci sono una serie di aneddoti che mi
piacerebbe raccontare perché ognuno di
essi rappresenta una piccola scoperta
che ho che ho fatto negli anni il primo
aneddoto riguarda questo piccolo cactus
premetto di solito e cactus per la
quantità di acqua che hanno al loro
interno producono un flusso sonoro
praticante continuo e io ero lì che
stava facendo i miei esperimenti come
vedete nell'immagine con i miei
strumenti euro dato una caratteristica
unica che non ho mai trovato nessun
altro quando lasciamo la stanza il
cactus smetteva di suonare e allora io
ho cominciato a fare degli esperimenti
uscito dalla stanza mi affacciavo così
con la testa nella stanza e lui se ne
accorgeva è cominciato a suonare e io li
ho cominciato a capire quanto fosse
veramente importante considerare ogni
essere vivente come unico e irripetibile
un altro esempio è l'invidia delle
piante e gli ho dato anche un titolo che
secondo me neanche stefano mancuso è
riuscito ad arrivare a tanto
ero su un tavolo fece voglio i miei
esperimenti la mamma della fidanzata mi
portò la sua pianta preferito dal
balcone perché queste due piante che
avevo scelto non ne volevano sapere
minimamente di suonare appena questa via
pianta da preferita è entrata nella
stanza queste due immediatamente hanno
cominciato a suonare e allora qui
un'altra un'altra sorpresa nvidia paura
di essere sostituite o semplicemente
segnali chimici che è uno scienziato
potrebbe individuare non lo so però
comunque che in questo caso il quello
che hanno dato è stato il cambiamento e
reventino improvviso del comportamento
di una pianta di solito cambiano dalla
mattina al pomeriggio può succedere ma
in questo in questo caso è stato una
cosa veramente pazzesca che non è mai
successa altre volte il terzo esempio
enel ed hera qui non c'entra più la
mamma della fidanzata ma centra la mia
durante la prima installazione
realizzato con questo sistema il bio
data
io ho invitato anche la mamma
giustamente e gli ho raccontato mamma
questa sera non vuole funzionare c'è da
dire una cosa di solo dell'etere come
gli arbusti gli alberi hanno una pelle
un po troppo spessa che di solito non è
molto recettiva invece mia mamma validi
sia vicino al ed era appena cominciato a
carla parte la chiacchierata e allora
anche qui evidentemente gli esseri umani
hanno delle caratteristiche che possono
essere molto unica e molto preziosa e
quindi questo sistema continua a
regalarmi sorprese ogni volta che lo uso
un'altra cosa che mi piacerebbe molto
portarvi come esperienza e quella delle
installazioni
io credo che sia giusto dire che molte
di queste installazioni hanno avuto un
grande riscontro di pubblico lo dico non
perché voglio vantarmi di quello che
sono riuscito a fare con le persone con
cui ho lavorato
ma lo voglio dire perché quando le
persone davanti a una cosa del genere
riescono ad emozionarsi riesce ad essere
c'è cambiare il loro sguardo e vedo che
ieri bolle qualcosa dentro che a quel
punto grado di aver raggiunto il
risultato perché di risvegliare
il l'interesse e la passione verso
l'esplorazione di se stessi e delle
proprie sensazioni credo che sia una
cosa molto importante per tutti noi
la prima installazione di cui vi parlo
si chiama acus ma 01 e la prima con cui
mi sono cimentato con il bio data nella
foto accessibile parolin una mia amica a
designer e led era di prima di cui vi
parlavo che l'ha voluta fotografare
quella volta lì
praticamente un gruppi di piante con
tutte collegate fra di loro e
un'atmosfera un po psichedeliche con
delle luci fluorescenti
lì ho cominciato a vedere la reazione
delle persone lacrime baci ai cactus
balli e statici insomma è stata
un'esperienza molto molto interessante
qui ci sono alcuni piccoli dettagli dove
si vede appunto in un pochino questa
installazione molto piccola ma molto
densa
il secondo è lavoro che vorrei citarvi
si chiama secret garden
immaginate di entrare in un parcheggio
sotterraneo con questa rampa di cemento
e ritrovarvi in un ambiente del genere
completamente coperto di piante verde
dello stadio del
dello stadio riciclato dalle dal terreno
odori profumi questa luce che filtra
tutte queste piante che ti avvolgevano
che filtrava attraverso una nebbia finta
che perdeva che ti persona va
completamente perdere la proporzione è
l'immagine che tu potevi avere un po
dello spazio e quindi una sorpresa
ulteriore di questo ambiente così magico
e fatato era il fatto che certe volte
sfiorando qualcuna di queste piante
poteva succedere queste piante
rispondevano e allora scattava
l'esplorazione e la ricerca data dalla
sorpresa e allora vedevi persone che
chiamavano amici che cominciavano a
coinvolgere tutto questo
tutto questo gruppo in questi
esperimenti
diciamo anche questa ad un'esperienza
bella perché riuscire a dare la
possibilità alle persone di mandar fuori
dal loro immaginario mentale dai loro
schemi
sono sempre quel cambiamento di punto di
vista che mi interessa
la terza invece molto diversa perché non
contempla la presenza del bio data e
quindi non è un'installazione
interattiva ma si tratta di una camera
immersiva
si chiama resize vulcano
anche questa come la precedente
realizzata col mitico architetto e
designer diego repetto che un mio
carissimo amico conquistò facendo
diversi lavori in questo caso è una
camera magmatica
all'interno della quale c'è questo totem
riscaldato vibrante che emette una luce
rossa che illumina tutto questo fumo
subwoofer che ti fanno tremare le
budella è un suono avvolgente e
multicanale che riesce a farti sentire
come appunto all'interno del contenitore
della lava di un vulcano quindi pietra
che scricchiolano suoni forti ma
viscerali e contemporaneamente un
atmosfera molto raccolta è molto calda
noi non sapevamo come cosa aspettarci
volevamo un'esperienza forte abbiamo
ricevuto come feedback
una bella risposta ma in particolare
quello che mi piace ricordare che la
maggior parte dei bambini uscendo da
questa installazione
sentendo sentendo questi suoni sentendo
questo strano
dall'ambiente vedendosi così che si
struttura così
così definita e così
come dire monolitica comunque si
sistemano a loro agio perché era la
prima è la curiosità della scoperta che
dava questa sensazione di sorpresa e di
esplorazione di un mondo un po
particolare come vedere da queste
immagini
tutti questi stimoli però che cosa mi
portano a pensare
tutti questi stimoli formiano potete
pensare che è necessario per l'uomo
ritornare in contatto con la natura
perché la prima cosa che succede quando
l'uomo si stacca
non riconoscere più il proprio habitat
quindi comincerà non interessarsene fino
a rischiare di distruggerlo come succede
abbiamo vediamo anche abbastanza che sta
succedendo i nostri giorni
quindi uscire da questo flusso impedisce
all
le persone di rimanere collegati a
rimanere sintonia noi dobbiamo renderci
conto che bisogna
continuare ad essere dentro questo
flusso e continuare ad avere un rapporto
equilibrato con la natura
lui questo è l'unico modo per riuscire a
continuare ad arricchirci alle ricche
del pianeta e andare avanti in una
maniera più positiva ma possibile
quello che mi verrebbe da sottolineare
del bio dato è che il principale
arricchimento che questa questo sistema
può portare agli esseri umani è proprio
la riscoperta di se stessi il
cambiamento profondo di punto di vista
rispetto all'ambiente circostante
quindi che quello che credo è che
bisognerebbe ritornare dentro questo
flusso in maniera responsabile
e in maniera concreta e senza perdere
troppo tempo per citare stefano concluso
che ha scritto la carta dei diritti
delle piante che è un interessante anche
questo interessante cambio di punto di
vista l'articolo 1 recita la terra e
casa comune della vita
la sovranità appartiene ad ogni essere
vivente
quindi io
concludo con un messaggio
che riassume un po tutto questo discorso
che ascoltiamo noi stessi e ascoltiamo
la natura
[Applauso]
[Musica]